good
[Music]
today tuesday december 15 these are the
most outstanding headlines of the
day hospitals are already distributing
the coronavirus vaccines today the
doses began to be administered to
workers in the public health sector
yesterday at the johns hospital and the first
of 200  dose was administered to a
nurse who worked caring for
coronavirus patients the
hospital chief yesterday said more shipments are anticipated
and the general public will be able to
start receiving the vaccines in late
January or early February well
before the  dates originally
forecast the rest of the state could
have access to vaccines this
spring
and nevada state's unemployment rate
remains among the highest
in the entire country this as people
around the valley struggle to
stay in their homes today was activated
a new rent moratorium that
seeks to protect tenants from being
evicted from their homes this
moratorium  The moratorium replaces the current
federal extension of the Center for
Disease Control that expires on
December 31 the new moratorium extends
until March 31
the pandemic has been a severe blow to
several industries including
entertainment and just a month after
having  started to reopen its
shows the hotel company
investors announced on Monday that it would
reopen all its shows until mid
-January to comply with the
restrictions of the extension to the
state pause the company has suspended
all sales to its shows until January 15
now  when the weather forecast
expects a sunny day with a
bit of breeze and temperatures in the
high 50s for the rest of the week
today's maximum 55 degrees and minimum 34
have a good day I am salí jaramillo and
this was news now in  Spanish
[Music]